Harvard University overnight rescinded a
fellowship invitation to Chelsea Manning
she is a transgender former soldier
convicted of giving classified
information to WikiLeaks the decision
comes after CIA director Mike Pompeo
cancelled the campus speaking event at
the last minute last night and former
acting CIA director and CBS News
contributor Michael Morell resigned a
university post Harvard's Kennedy School
Dean said in a statement quote
designating Chelsea Manning as a
visiting fellow was a mistake for which
I accept responsibility Jeff PJ's is in
Washington Jeff good morning Manning's
leaks and pardons still sting the
intelligence community and that's why
the reaction from its leaders was so
Swift officials will tell you that US
national security was severely injured
by those leaks and to this day is still
trying to recover I'm very sorry to have
to announce that the CIA director will
not be speaking here tonight the Dean of
Harvard's Kennedy School apologized
yesterday for the absence of CIA
director Mike Pompeo Pompeo a former
West Point and Harvard graduate laid out
his reasoning for his withdrawal in this
letter to the school calling Chelsea
Manning a traitor
Harvard's actions implicitly tell its
students that you too can be a fellow at
Harvard and a felon under United States
law Chelsea Manning then Bradley Manning
a former Army Intel analyst was
convicted in 2013 for leaking classified
information to WikiLeaks and sentenced
to 35 years in prison
she served seven years after President
Obama commuted her sentence last May
intelligence leaders maintained
Manning's leaks put Americans in danger
in that WikiLeaks is an enemy to the
United States it directed Chelsea
Manning in her theft of specific secret
information it overwhelmingly focuses on
the United States earlier in the day
former acting CIA director Michael
Morell submitted his resignation as a
Harvard senior fellow saying the
school's invitation to Manning was
wholly inappropriate adding I cannot be
part of an organization that honors our
convicted
Chelsea Manning responded to the
intelligence leaders and Harvard by
tweeting a number of messages including
this one that says honored to be first
disinvited trans woman visiting Harvard
fellow they chill marginalized voices
under CIA pressure morale called the
Kennedy School to Dean's decision the
right one and said it showed quote real
leadership as it is rare for senior
officials at any institution to admit
making mistake
Nora quite a story Jeff thank you so
much